We know for example,
that if you provide children with food and shelter and an adequate food and
shelter,
but you don't interact with them socially,
almost all of them die in the first year.
Right?
It's not optional.
Touch is not optional for children.
Attention is not optional for children.
Play is not optional for children.
So it isn't just like,
well the child comes into the world with a set of reflexes and can adapt to any
old environments like know the environment has to be structured in a certain way
or the child will die.
And it's very interesting when it comes to things like play and touch because
you wouldn't think of those as fundamental necessities.
Right?
But it turns out that they are,
if you deprive a child badly enough of play and touch in the first three years
of their life,
even if they survive,
what comes out at the end of that is often something that's like barely
recognizable as a functional human being and cannot be repaired after that
point.
And that that experiment was done with Romanian orphans back in back in the 90s
so it was a,
it was an ugly situation to say the least.